[Music]
he made millions and millions of dollars
a year Ukraine took care of him
how about China he walked out with 1.5
billion to manage and he never did it
before he didn't know anything about oil
and gas he was making a fortune
so where's hunter where the hell are you
hunter I sort of hope it's Joe because
he will here where's hunter every single
debate nine times at the day I was a
president last night asking questions
the mainstream media mob should be
asking never will force instead
Democratic contenders like Oh Elizabeth
Warren they're getting cushy pup pieces
like this one focused on her skincare
routine
anybody want to know about mine
meanwhile over there a conspiracy TV
Roswell Rachel Maddow area 51 conspiracy
DNC Channel well they're talking and
taking an in-depth look at the
resemblance between Bernie Sanders and
Larry David we have the tape
I'm here with Curb Your Enthusiasm is
Larry David no wait
[Music]
Curb Your Enthusiasm is Larry David but
the here they are together if you become
president you've got to be flying back
and forth yes it plays him yes it is
true it's not going to be easy for me
it'll be great for the country and
terrible for me give you a good job for
four years in you're complaining they're
not related at all I love Trump ever get
that kind of coverage no all right
joining us now former White House press
secretary Fox News contributor Sarah
Sanders Michael best slaw president
former GOP Chairman Reince Priebus prime
right you got to get back in the game I
told this to mark Meadows earlier I
think we need you back in the game I'm
appointing you something I don't know
what but look you watch what they do to
the president now we're gonna have the
the shift' show sham show impeachment
show that'll end very quickly
expeditiously next week Sarah and but
this has been every single day we have
our montage we run it all the time you
Pietschmann two days after he's elected
impeachment through 2017 18 and 19 now
they impeach him over nothing because
they didn't get what they wanted from
Muller but the American people speak out
in 298 days how does this play out look
I think that it plays out exactly how we
thought it would from the very beginning
we know it's been a huge waste of time a
huge waste of taxpayer dollars and
frankly it hasn't played well for
Democrats
we saw them push every single day
telling us how urgent it was to get
impeachment done and now all of a sudden
we have all the time in the world to sit
back and wait while Nancy Pelosi gets
controlled more and more by the far left
wing of her party and refuses to send
the papers to the Senate it's been a
sham from day one it's gonna be wiped
away in the Senate and I think it's
gonna be a great day to watch the
president get fully vindicated in the
Senate and then get to stand in front of
Nancy Pelosi and all of her crazy
colleagues as he delivers a beautiful
and amazing State of the Union and talks
about all the successes of his last
three years as president I think it's
gonna be a great day you know let's just
for a second let's look 298 days down
the road Reince Priebus and I gotta be
honest I want everybody in this country
to understand what is at stake here this
is America literally on the brink the
America freedom you know the 94 trillion
dollar and ten year new Green Deal the
52 trillion dollar Medicare for all deal
we can't afford any of this but and I
always want to play like you're behind a
touchdown no timeouts you have down by
six and you need the touchdown and an
extra point in two minutes doing the
two-minute drill that's how everyone
should look at this elect well look at
her behind but here's my question
imagine that we get these words we can
now project Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th president the United
States they're gonna lose their minds
all of them the mob they're gonna raise
their butt look at this week I mean the
week started on a knife's edge with Iran
turns out that the president made the
right call turns out Iran retreated then
we had a solid jobs report today
and the key middle way middle-class wage
growth up three to five percent you know
the same thing happened in 2016 Sean I
remember days on the plane I'm sure
Sarah does too where the president would
open up the New York Times and not just
find one bad story on the front page but
every day some days every single story
on the front page was bad everyone said
he can't win he's wasting your time
you're wasting your money at the RNC and
on obviously an election night president
Trump wins the presidency and shocks the
world so back to the hunter Biden issue
though you know IIIi think the
Republicans might want to consider
getting very bold about this exert
executive privilege over John Bolton
exert executive executive privilege over
Mick Mulvaney Colin hunter Biden and
find out what the truth is because the
center of the Democrats case is that you
know was it reasonable for the president
to ask about about Biden well if that's
the center of their case we'll bring in
Biden and with just a great executive
privilege over the rest I want all that
to happen but I go ahead but the house
present their weak case the Senate
listens to their weak case that's their
sole responsibility impeachment tells
why you impeach them then call the roll
get this gone then investigate mr. quid
pro quos you know you're not getting the
billion unless you fire the guy that's
investigating my zero experience son
being paid millions that needs to be
getting to the bottom of because that's
the very thing I thought they were
supposed to be upset about right well
it's time to make them nervous about the
games that they're playing today with
the United States Senate and I think
hunter Biden is going to be a big issue
I do think we need to be careful not to
play it all of it too early where if it
gets get sold potentially in the general
election but hunter Biden should be
investigated and there needs to be a
strategy behind it last word what what
do you think about do you agree with me
Sarah should we just call the roll get
this done yeah but then I think they
should investigate hunter and zero
experienced hunters little quid pro quo
absolutely I say we get this impeachment
sham over with and out of the way and
let's look into the Biden's eye I think
that there is so much
information there look Joe Biden has
spent half a century in the Washington
DC swamp the last thing we need after
President Trump has come in and drained
it is to have the Biden's come back and
fill it up again I think we ought to
clear the deck get the impeachment out
of the way but let's look into all of
the corruption and make that part of the
campaign if need be well said both of
you are